es sind ja nicht nur rechtsextreme also
steinmeier spricht jetzt vor allem von
rechtsextremen aber es sind ja auch
linke es sind tipp ist in kramp anhänger
all diese leute die normalerweise
überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun
haben laufen da auf dieser demo
gemeinsam
wie kann das sein also ich glaube auch
dass dieses dieses mit rechtsextremismus
diese kategorie mit der frank walter
steinmeier versucht hat einen großen
teil der demo zu beschreiben das
phänomen nicht so richtig fast das kommt
daher dass dieses dass diese kategorie
dieses clearing system rechtsextremismus
auf dass er sich da bezieht das stammt
eigentlich noch so aus der alten
bundesrepublik
und diese demonstration dieser dieser
bewegung die wir dort gesehen haben am
samstag die war im prinzip etwas neues
da wurden da waren vor allem nicht mehr
partei fahren des klassischen
organisierten rechtsextremismus
tonangebend auch nur marginal vorhanden
wir haben zwar viele funktionäre von npd
und auch am stiel gesehen jeder mit
marschiert sind
aber parteien waren da eben nicht mehr
vorhanden und auch freie kameradschaften
und dergleichen waren da nicht
tonangebend und der bundespräsident hat
er gesagt dass da leute mit marschiert
sind mit rechts mit rechtsextremen das
ist aber nicht nur so dass die mit
marschiert sind sondern die haben
teilweise in einem meer von schwarz weiß
roten fahnen diesen mitgetragen und ihre
selbst gebastelten schilder gehabt mit
friedensvertrag also mit einer forderung
nach souveränität also mit diesen
hirngespinsten die eigentlich so aus der
reichs bürger szene stammen und
natürlich waren auch richtige reichs
bürgerfonds ich glaube aber dass diese
ganzen leute die sich dort was ich hab'
ich war auch dort vor ort und habe mit
vielen gesprochen die sich innerhalb
kürzester zeit politisiert haben die
sich erst innerhalb dieser corona krise
mit mit politischen inhalten beschäftigt
haben und dann auf dieser schwarz weiß
roten fahnen auf diese cueni channels
auf auf raichs bürger inhalte gestoßen
sind
dass die eben keiner politischen
ideologie folgen wie die reichs bürger
selber sondern dass sie tatsächlich
diese inhalte benutzen ohne dass sie
komplett wissen was was für diese stehen
also wenn sie zum beispiel von
souveränität sprechen dann ist da nicht
von
wie es bei den reis bürgern gemeint ist
mit von politischen oder politisch zu
verwendet wird deutschlands die rede die
reichsburg behaupten ja dass deutschland
kein zuwanderungsland raack sondern ganz
viele von diesen leuten die dort
marschieren und die man als normalbürger
klassifizieren würde um menschen denen
man an der supermarktkasse steht und die
dann auf einmal sich schilder umgehängt
haben mit friedensvertrag das sind leute
glaube ich die ganz viele schwerwiegende
persönliche einschnitte erlebt haben
während dieser kroner krise die ohnmacht
erfahrungen hatten und die dann auf
einmal diese dieses dieses wort
souveränität im prinzip als eine art
selbstermächtigung des individuums
wieder zurück für sich sozusagen
reklamieren und die auch also ich hab
das auch erlebt
das steht so ein bisschen im widerspruch
zu den erfahrungen die journalisten
kollegen von mir gemacht haben die
aggressiv angepöbelt wurden
ich selber hatte tatsächlich wenn man
mit den leuten ins gespräch kamen
wenn ich die erfahrung gemacht die waren
sehr zugänglich nicht nur zugänglich
sondern die wollten tatsächlich alle
reden jahr den großen redebedarf und war
noch relativ freundlich dabei das heißt
dieses friedensvertrag was ihr die ganze
zeit von frieden und zweiter erzählten
das scheint mir quasi die summe er hat
sich nur sehnsucht nach gemeinschaft
diese leute die unter vereinzelt
gelitten haben wenn der korona krise die
mit irgendwelchen einbußen leben mussten
die wahrscheinlich auch unter
schwerwiegenden stress standen also ich
hatte teilweise mit mitteln gesprochen
die auch ganz gute theorien hatten zum
verhalten ihrer kinder was durch impfung
hervorgerufen sei wohl schon nach kurzem
nachfragen klar war dass es vermutlich
sind sie überfordert damit ihre kinder
zu hause zu haben weil diese nicht in
kita oder kindergärten gehen können und
dann laufen diese diese damen die sich
vor wenigen wochen noch nicht für
politik interessierten auf einmal mit
großem selbst gebastelt schildern herum
auf den friedensvertrag und irgendwas
von souveränität steht also da glaube
ich das ist eine irgendwie post
ideologische und post politische
bewegung in großen teilen die mit dem
begriff rechtsextremismus sowie in der
bundespräsident genannt hat nicht zu
fassen ist
das ist etwas was ja was aus diesem
muster ein klassisch linksextremismus
und rechtsextremismus ausbricht